command the seas with history's most
iconic war vessels in the latest
free-to-play combat game world of
warships download now hey guys i'm lucy
and welcome to reality check now as a
heads-up this video is sponsored by
wargaming more specifically their brand
new seafaring MMO world of warships
which got me thinking mmo's get a lot of
flack shouldn't you go out and socialize
with your friends i'm logged on to an
MMORPG with people from all over the
world and getting XP with my party using
teamspeak but as anyone who has actually
played an MMO can testify they can
actually have a really positive effect
on us so here's three areas of your life
that could be improved by playing mmo's
take your social life it can get a real
boost by playing online studies like
this one way Nicholas Taylor and
colleagues have found that online gaming
can supplement or even enhance our
social lives but how well mmo's over
every other type of game offer an
environment where collaboration teamwork
and most importantly fun are not only
encouraged but crucial to get the
maximum amount of enjoyment from a game
you have to work together so hopefully
the more you work together the more
successful you'll be at the game so the
more you'll bond with the people you're
playing with think about it if you trust
someone enough to have your back in the
game or spot enemies or give you items
when you need them you're more likely to
trust that person in real life and Trust
is a key part of any relationship
a study by Cole and Griffiths found that
MMO gamers created strong friendships
and emotional relationships and they
concluded that it was partly due to the
gameplay and partly due to the
environment
em'ly most present a space where players
can express themselves in ways they
might not be able to do in real life you
can make friends who know the real you
and your relationships are stronger for
it we've all got either first-hand
experience or heard anecdotes of friends
who met years ago in guilds or online
who played games together and who have
remained friends since occasionally
people who meet in mmo's even get
married it's actually more common than
you'd think
now over the years I've learned a lot
from games how to go to bed properly how
to survive solely on
in food and most importantly that if the
police can't see you they will stop
coming after you although admittedly
they've not been very useful skills for
my everyday but we live in an age where
pilots and even soldiers can be trained
using simulators
so while mmo's aren't exactly job
simulators are we picking up anything
useful from them well according to
researchers from the University of
Newcastle and the University of Crete
apparently so
the researchers investigated the
behaviors of 79 MMORPG players over the
course of a month and it turns out that
leadership skills and behaviors they
learnt in the games they played were
transferring into their work life skills
like allocating resources working
together to overcome puzzles recruiting
new players strategizing to take down
enemy teams or tough bosses ok maybe
don't take out your boss in real life
but all these skills seem to pour over
into the gamers workplace interestingly
the research also found that those who
are particularly successful in game were
way more likely to utilize these
behaviors offline maybe to try and
emulate their virtual selves the
researchers also suggested that virtual
worlds could be useful to teach people
leadership skills in the future I mean
we already have conferences online
training courses webinars what's to say
that learning via video games isn't
gonna be the next big thing well it's
funny you should say that past me
because in some classrooms around the
world that's actually happening Shaun
young invented a new teaching system
called class craft and instead of being
a teacher leading a room of pupils he's
the game's master
reading warriors mages healers on a
quest for knowledge normal teaching
methods emphasize the individual but
Young's creation encourages young people
to work together but unlike teammates in
MMOs
kid get xp for participating in class
which they can then use to level up and
bank to earn rewards a mage can teleport
out of the classroom for a couple of
minutes or a warrior can eat food during
lessons of course it works the other way
too
bad behavior earns damage to the kids
characters if you take too much your
character dies but in this case dying
just means rolling a dice to choose your
punishment and there's a range of those
on offer like copying lines or even
detention which is kind of like a
dungeon if you think about it so the
formula that MMOs are built on
collaborating with others continue
feedback from the game and earning
significant rewards all feed together to
make a classroom experience that seeing
results teachers are reporting that kids
are more engaged and eager to
participate not to mention their grades
are leveling up - so what do you reckon
applying mmo's the best way to get ahead
let me know in the comment section below
or come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games thanks for watching this
week's reality check and I'll see you
next time